Okay. I'm currently pregnant with baby number two,
and I wanna share, like,
all the things that I take instead of a prenatal,
because I always get asked,
what prenatal do you take?
I don't take a prenatal. I've never taken a prenatal.
And actually, this pregnancy,
I'm taking a lot more things than I was last time,
because I know more information this time.
I'm more informed. Um,
but I do wanna say this is just.
I'm not giving any advice or anything.
It's just what I do and what works for me.
Grass fed beef liver capsules,
I cannot tolerate. I know beef liver.
Like, you can eat actual beef liver.
Like, I think it's like once or twice a week,
mom, on of it will be good,
but I just cannot tolerate beef liver at all.
It's just. It's disgusting to me.
So I do beef liver capsules have basically, like,
all your vitamins, like,
all your, um,
B vitamins, vitamin A,
all the good stuff. Then I take vitamin C.
I typically take a different brand,
but this brand sent me these,
so I'm currently using. Vitamin C is just, like,
so important for, like,
the structure of babies, bones, teeth,
immune system, things like that.
So not all vitamin C is the same.
Go to a regular store and you walk in,
the most vitamin C that you'll see is from absorbent acid,
which that's not what you want
because that's an incomplete form of Vitamin C.
You want a whole food form of vitamin C.
Like, a bunch of brands out there.
This one, the one from Perfect Supplements that I typically take free,
basically freeze dried cherry. Um,
and that's the complete form of vitamin C.
Next, one of my favorites,
which is cod liver oil. Um,
I take this fermented cod liver oil from green pasture.
Um, it's not have anything added or anything.
And is it, like,
any fillers or additives or anything?
And then I take. I rotate cod liver oil with beef liver,
since they both have vitamin A.
I do, like,
one day beef liver capsules,
one day cod liver oil.
But cod liver oil is so important because it has vitamin A,
vitamin D, which is so,
so important for, like, babies,
brain development, eye development.
Next thing that I take is.
I don't even know if I'm gonna pronounce this right. Shilajit.
It's basically full of minerals.
Stay with this. You cannot start taking this if you are already pre.
Like, if you haven't taken this before,
you're pregnant. It has a detox effect.
Another thing I take is bee pollen.
I add this to my, like, smoothies,
my daily smoothies and, like,
protein shakes. Um,
bee pollen has vitamins, copper.
Only need a small amount of this.
You don't wanna overdo it.
Show powder. It sounds weird,
but you won't taste it. I added to my shakes.
I think I have a TikTok on, like,
How I make this, it's super,
super simple. I make it with eggshells,
and I just add a tiny bit about my shakes,
and it's really, really good for Calcium.
Now let's talk about Bruce.
Loaded with, like, thing, iron,
phonium, selenium,
B vitamins, and it has folate,
which I don't take, folic acid.
I only take folate. Um,
I take it to, like,
the foods that I eat. Obviously,
I eat, like,
a really good diet. Um,
but on top of that, I do,
like, to add Bruce yeast to, like,
my chocolate chip cookies that I make.
And then on top of that, I.
I take this three times a week with water,
a collagen every single day with my milk at night.
Magnesium. I take magnesium glycinate.
So magnesium helps convert, um,
the storage form of vitamin D into the active form of vitamin D.
So you need magnesium. This is just what works for me.
I am planning to add a vitamin K,
like, the last three months.
I know it sounds like a lot,
but a lot of the stuff I just add to my smoothies,
and all the stuff I don't take every day,
I take it, like,
a couple times a week. So that's all.